Por ejemplo, cuando Jennifer Kahn
quiso explicar la increíble nueva biotecnología llamada CRISPR,
dijo: "Es como si, por primera vez,
tuviésemos un editor de texto para editar el ADN.
CRISPR permite cortar y pegar la información genética muy fácilmente".
Una explicación tan gráfica como esa crea un momento ajá
conforme se forma en la mente.
Es importante, por lo tanto, probar la charla con personas de confianza
y averiguar qué partes resultan confusas.
Y el cuarto, este es el consejo final:
Hagan que valga la pena compartir la idea.
Con eso me refiero a que se pregunten:
"¿A quién beneficia esta idea?"
Y necesito que la respuesta sea honesta.
Si la idea solo les sirve a Uds. o a su organización,
entonces, lo siento, quizá no valga la pena difundirla.
El público lo notará en Uds.
Pero si Uds. creen
que la idea tiene el potencial para alegrarle el día a alguien
o cambiar la perspectiva de otra persona para mejor,
o inspirar a alguien a hacer algo de manera diferente,
entonces tienen el ingrediente central para una charla genial,
que puede ser un regalo para ellos y para todos nosotros.